i think i can because it has maybe not
on a specific like cause effect way you
know i mean if if some musician writes a
song about some policy initiatives they
want to see moved forward through
Congress I don't know if necessarily you
know Rahm Emanuel is going to hear this
song and be inspired to move policy
through Congress but but I think that I
mean that music and politics have been
intertwined for such a long time
sometimes in very explicit ways I mean
have like vaclav havel who was very
involved in the Czech music scene it was
really inspired by The Velvet
Underground and a lot of rock music in
the states in the 60s and music
Strangelove music has always been more
political than politics has been musical
you know and because politicians are
nerds you know at the end of the day
they're nerds who will do anything they
can to get elected whereas you know I
think musicians oddly enough have a
slightly broader view doesn't mean
there's they're brighter it doesn't mean
they're better informed it just means
that I think that a musician can
approach his or her world with a little
more objectivity and they're a little
more a little more personal for them so
that's why I think music thus I think
politics has influenced music in a way
much more than the music isn't
Oh